vous avez évoqué dans votre exposé donc
la Guyane et en ce moment ils ont mis
donc un dispositif de contrôle à 100 %pr
les aéroports alors la population est
excédée mais les policiers également ils
sont fatigués puceque hier j'ai pris
l'avion pour venir pour rentrer à Paris
et j'ai échangé avec quelques policiers
de la PAF et qui me disait madame la
sénatrice aidez-nous on comprend hein
qu'il faille mettre des moyen pour
eniguer ce fléo parce que chez nous
c'est un fléo et ça touche pas
uniquement les jeunes puisque hier au
départ de de Félix et Boué ils ont
empêché 52 passagers de prendre l'avion
et parmi il y avait une dame qui qui
partait en évacuation sanitaire donc
elle en avait sur le fauteil elle en
avait sur elle donc elle pensait qu'en
partant voilà on sous assistance
médicale qu'elle aurait pas été fouillée
et en fait ben voilà voilà des cas et
donc moi je comprends hein ce sont des
moyens on essaie de mettre mais je
remarque en tout cas le constat que je
fais c'est que ben ça continue ça
continue de plus en plus l'autre l'autre
déplacement que je fais il y a 82
personnes qui n'ont pas pu prendre
l'avion parce que Ben
ell portait ou elles avaient ingéré des
des des ovules et donc
donc ça veut dire que en fait le
contrôle à 100 % n'arrête pas puisque'il
y en a quand même les gens n'ont pas
peur ils viennent ils savent que vous
rentrez pas dans l'aérogin si la police
ne vous pose pas les questions quand
vous êtes en face de jeunes qui viennent
en tong et à qui on demande mais vous
allez où je vais à Arcachon mais ils
connaissent pas ils connaissent même pas
des fois ils n'ont jamais pris l'avion
il ils partent pour la première fois
mais le le la pas du gain des 4000 €
qu'on leur a promis quand il va arriver
à à horly voilà les poussent à le faire
c'est vrai qu'on a une grande précarité
une grande pauvreté chez nous mais enfin
en tout cas le moyen les moyens mis en
place bah ne ne permettent pas de
ralentir donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
il faut qu'on trouve une solution parce
que c'est pas possible nous sommes en
Amérique du Sud et et la production de
cocaïne elle est elle est elle est dans
le elle est sur ce territoire donc
forcément la Guyane est un transit pour
pouvoir amener la cocaïne en France donc
voilà moi je suis pour les moyens je
suis pour le contrôle à 100 % je l'avais
dit mais quand je constate que bah il y
a autant sinon plus les gens vont ils
partent il il vont quand même et on les
arrête on les empêche de voyager 5 jours
enfin il y a un arrêté préfectoral qui
est pris et cetera mais moi j'aurais
tellement aimé qu'on trouve une solution
et même de manière législative également
comme même la sénatrice sur sur la
Guyane
je je suis heureux de vous entendre dire
que 52 passagers ont été empêchés hier
effectivement c'est une une méthode que
le ministre d'intérieur des outresmèes a
souhaité mettre en œre c'est d'empêcher
le départ
des des mules c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle avec une stratégie des
trafiquant qui est de dire avant que ce
système
n'existe sur un vol on on met 40 mules
on sait que la douane et la police n'ur
la capacité d'en traiter aller au
maximum que 5 ou si donc en fait c'est
c'est la part qu'on accepte de perdre
pour que 35 réussissent à arriver à
destination donc la la stratégie
effectivement c'est c'est pénible pour
les forces mais on y a
aussi mis mis les moyens mais je pense
que que l'enjeu est est déterminant à la
fois pour empêcher que cette cocaïne
arrive dans l'Hexagone mais aussi pour
décourager ces pauvres gens qui sont les
victimes des trafiquants les premières
victimes de ces trafiquants pour avoir
assisté à une procédure d'embarquement à
Cayenne on voit bien il y en a qui qui
sont capable de répondre à la première
des questions qui ont juste un sac
plastique pour faire le voyage voilà qui
porte sur eux les 2 3 4 kg de cocaïne
pour arriver à destination parler du du
body sccan la difficulté à laquelle on
est confronté c'est la présence d'un
médecin en fait pour procéder à ce qui
spparente à un examin médical et là
aussi c'est toujours pareil la
disponibilité des des médecins étant
étant scalé ça ça rend les choses ça
rend les choses extrêmement
compliqué et on voit bien d'ailleurs
pour continuer sur ce que vous évoquiez
tous les deux sur ces systèmes on voit
bien qu'on commence à assister à un
déport
de de ces candidats au départ vers
l'Hexagone c'estàdire au lieu de prendre
le vol direct Cayen Paris Orly en fait
ils font Cayenne la gaeloupe ou la
Martinique pour rebondir et espérer
moins attirer l'attention en venant de
donc les avions n'étant pas contrôlés de
manière aussi systématique à destination
de des ti euh de de pouvoir contourner
le le bouclier qui qui est mis en place